- No, they're letting,
they're letting Gary up, okay?
They're letting Gary,
they're letting Gary up.
They're letting Gary up.
All right, they're letting him up, okay?
(even-paced music)
(yells)
- Nice. Woo!
(yelling)
- [Man in red] Why you fuck around?
- [Man in white] I love you man.
- [DRock] How do you feel about that?
- What do you think?
When nobody's watching, DRock,
when nobody's watching.
(laughing)
- You hit and you have
the game winner now.
That's like an all time
Vaynerchuk brother thing.
- I feel like Tyler was killing last game,
and that's why he put a hand in his face.
- No, then you got words, we
got what we needed though.
- We played well.
We played well.
- DRock I'm pissed, I'm super angry.
Have a great day.
- [Voiceover] Thanks, you too.
- Leavin' basketball early
to go to your 7:30 AM,
7:30 AM business breakfast.
(traffic humming)
Like I just think you could sell, ya know,
50, 60, 70 cases extra every day,
and this is the time to do it.
This is the time people need it.
The client and employee gift.
I'm just great.
Holiday
party comma employee
and client gift bonanza.
(upbeat instrumental music)
Ya know?
- [Gary] First and
foremost, I just wanna say
how much I appreciate
all the comments to the
Instagram photos around the show.
I just really appreciate,
the feedback's incredible.
Omar saying, "Watching at 5 AM.
"Fire fire," love that.
This guy right here, Brian Bleefield
saying, "Love da fire!"
I love it too, my man.
Let's see, let's see what
Thadcox is saying here.
"When I was running our
family hotel, I would always
"give all the dog owners
a sausage at breakfast.
"Not for them, but their dog.
"They loved it.
"I did it because I like
dogs. Not to try and get
"favorable reviews.
"However, in return, I
had so many nice comments
"and recommendations,
this led to new customers.
"#sausagekarma."
Comments are my oxygen.
Ya know, when you're
putting out so much content,
and you're playing to long
game, and you're jabbing,
the only think that makes your jab sharp,
or more importantly, the
only thing that allows you
to continue to jab, is
the comments, and so I'm
very very grateful for all
the comments and the feedback
and the thoughts and the
love that I get to the
Instagram photos on the #AskGaryVee Show,
pictures I put up for each episode.
Thank you, thank you so much.
It really does help me
to continue to help you.
(sirens)
(calming instrumental music)
- RSE Ventures?
Don't come in here, DRock.
This meeting, this meeting is--
- [AJ] Will be recorded
for training purposes.
(laughing)
- [AJ] More than half
buy more than month-to-month.
- No I, I--
- That's a big, big deal.
- It's the reason I was
gonna work, it's religion.
We haven't even done the
part that matters.
- Where ya headed?
- Okay that was good.
Yep, This is you?
- Hello.
How are you?
- [Driver] I'm good, how are you?
- Great.
Yar.
Valuable content will always win.
There's never a problem with
the volume of great content.
There's only a problem of the volume
of shit content.
People, people care about
effort, and actually giving crap
and providing value.
Twitter video is an
incredible place to do that
and I'm stunned at how
many people are not doing
that for their communities.
Yes, Adam, that's a private
label of Wine Library's.
Ian and I and Brandon really worked on it
and are in love with it.
And I love the packaging.
Zach Moy, my designer at
VaynerMedia put that together.
Which has been a lot of fun
super excited about the project.
Matty M, I really appreciate it.
I'm trying,
good content is subjective
and so the fact that you think
it's good means a lot to me.
Thanks bro.
Judd thanks so much for
watching back in '08
Wine Library TV was amazing run.
Thanks for rediscovering me,
I appreciate it.
I just want to say thank
you for your attention.
The only thing I don't like
about the following me around
and keep this in mind,
I hate my bald spot.
I know it's harder from doing it from,
- Yeah.
- You know?
- There he is.
Hey Gary, Wayne Bennett, Nice to see you.
- [Gary] Good to see you.
- Likewise.
Come on in.
- Sorry we're running late.
- No worries.
I'm just calling Zach.
Yeah he's our keynote speaker.
- [Man behind camera] Let
him take the picture first.
- He's speaking to my manager now.
And I just told him.
My manager is going to check
with and we'll go let him.
- Yeah of course, yeah don't worry.
Well is there a place to buy shoes?
My man?
- [Man] I understand, I understand.
- Hey DRock?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- There not letting us upstairs
because I don't have shoes.
I just have sneakers.
Can't give my keynote.
- You're doing the ninth floor.
- Okay so I'm going to
take you to the back
and then when you're done,
I just ask you that, I'll show you the way
and then you just come back down.
- If you tell me to jump out the window...
- Yeah they're letting Gary up okay.
Alright they're letting him up, okay?
Alright bye, bye.
- Get Gary.
- He's here, he's the guy.
- It's good to see ya.
- Use the language okay?
(laughs)
- After two years of
working with VaynerMedia,
there is not a realer
person in this industry
than Gary Vaynerchuk.
We are excited to introduce
you to Gary Vaynerchuck,
CEO of VaynerMedia.
(applause)
- How many people in this
room, by show of hands,
and remember lying is the devil.
(laughs from audience)
- By show of hands,
and no have ass hands, full hands,
how many people in this
room have sent an emoji
via text in the last six months?
Go!
Hold on, hold them up.
I want everybody to look
around, hold them up.
An emoji.
(laughter)
I would bet to argue,
by the way that's almost everybody.
Good holding out, Michael.
(laughter)
I would argue that the far majority of you
didn't even know what an
emoji was 24 months ago,
yet you've sent one. There
are grown ass men in here,
who sent...
There are grown ass men in here,
who sent a piece of poop with eyes on it.
(laughter)
Do you know how pissed
I get when people say
that I'm a change agent
or a destructer?
I think I'm the most practical
fucking person in this room.
(laughter)
I do.
- You're going DRock right?
- [DRock] Yep.
- It was the right amount of f-bombs.
(soft instrumental music)
- Hey Kim, how are you?
Why don't you share it with her
and tell her this is your reality
and that me, you, her, Alexandria, Chris,
should all be involved in
the conversations around,
how do we deal with this?
We run a business, like you
don't go into Bergdorf's and say
"Hey Bergdorf's, this coat is 800 bucks,
"we're going to give you 600."
That's the best part of
about being a businessman.
There's a lot more businessmen and women
that are kept grinding at 70, 80, and 90.
There is no 50 year old athletes.
So, like professional.
So yeah it's much better
to be a businessman.
As a proxy to your psychology.
Your things that are brewing for 2016.
So something worth debating.
I don't think anything is a
good thing or a bad thing.
I think you should spend plenty
of time with your girlfriend
and I think you should
spend plenty of time
listening to my crap and getting better
what you should cut out is
all the other stuff.
Like, do you bowl?
Do you play games on your phone?
Are you watching House
of Cards? Breaking Bad?
There's other things to cut.
- [Voiceover] Floor fifteen.
- [Voiceover] Is it our floor?
- Hi.
Hey guys.
Looking sharp.
- We're gonna go get some
coffee, I won a gift card. Woo!
- Yay!
- [Voiceover] Floor sixteen.
- Sixteen that's us.
(office chatter)
- Did they push it
or did they just say?
I love this weight loss
thing. Feeling good.
- It's against?
- [Gary] Great.
- Yeah awesome.
- I need a coffee. Can you
let Demayo know?
I called a sitter actually.
Hello.
- Hello.
- Hey what up.
- Thanks bro.
- [Man] She came to us
and she asked us
to do some research around
with Romey's team.
We worked with the paid team
and came up with a rationale.
- This way.
- No, don't be so crooked.
- Well of course.
You could b-roll the rest of your life.
- Okay.
(laughter)
- I've learned something new
about Facebook, once a week.
And I spend all my day on Facebook.
- That's intimidating.
- And it's not as if we say,
"Gary, fire something away."
Like to understand this machine,
it's literally 20 minutes of Gary's time
in a room for the show.
- What is that real?
- Yeah you never sign like that.
- Yeah I do. That's when
I actually have a minute.
That's actually when I have half a second.
- I need you for 5 to 10 minutes
before you leave.
Flights, questions in your inbox.
- So we'll make that happen.
Oh I got a real curve ball for you.
I might have a Shiva
Call that I have to do.
- A what?
- A shiva call.
- It's like a funeral, I know
what you're talking about.
- Tonight.
- Okay great.
- How long until you're working here?
- A month.
- A month working into here, being here?
I walked out of my office and I said,
"Let's go film this show."
The #AskGaryVee show's first episode,
happened that random.
- [DRock] Like we
found questions right there
in the room. On the phone.
- Oh I didn't know that.
Actually you know what,
you know what for the
two year anniversary,
we should really make a movie,
like we should do maybe
what we're doing right now
as a story of how the
hell it even happened.
Anyway...
- Is that the camera you use for the...
- Yeah.
- Oh really.
- I was ready to give him a thousand bucks
for a thousand dollars session.
I literally said, "I'm going
to give you the money."
- Oh shit, I got to leave?
- [DRock] Yeah, yeah.
- [Man] No Ask Gary Vee.
- Okay.
- So you're shooting now?
- I was going to, but we ran out of time.
Okiedokie.
- Hi.
- Get that goddamn camera out of my face.
- This the day, he likes the middle seat.
- I like the middle seat, I'm not scared.
No.
Tell them I... Tell them
why would I do that,
if we don't have something
that's meaningful. That's stupid.
And they need to do it,
like what do they do?
You reply to them, CC me and say,
"Gary just balistically said, 'No, why?
'When the moderator is the
ROI of the rationale.'"
Otherwise who gives a rat's fucking ass.
You're in the dead horse business.
You have to beat that horse,
that's how you wrangle me.
I'm not, you never have
to hedge that again.
(laughs)
- Yeah go ahead. And no
and how much in pay?
What's going on with the
250,000 dollars in books dude.
And it will be on the back
book coming back a month later.
If you want to sell to millennial moms,
like TV stinks because
you have to go vanilla
and Facebook doesn't,
because I can put Korean women in it.
And Korean women will target it
and they convert better.
That is uniquely you.
Uniquely you, that you guys,
that we can make 87 videos,
mapping 87 significant groups
based on a magnitude of proxies.
Yet that is not in the
best interest of Star Com.
- If this was for educational,
what is, how are you
making your decisions?
Is it efficiency based?
- Usually, efficiency
is very high in scale.
That's what yesterday's conversation was?
- Yes.
- Yeah I mean anything
that is less efficient than it can be
that is not overly that
dramatically important
is stupid to not fix if you can.
- Okay, yeah.
- So that's number one.
That'll be 39, I'll be
back in the city anytime
to like come fish and hunt
and then I may want oysters
or not oysters, because they're too fat,
Cesar salad.
- I'll do whatever you want.
I don't give a shit.
Hello.
- [Mike] I know
right, but if you're...
- I'll be chill, then you'll see.
I met with Doc, lovely man.
- Here are the days.
- Why'd you cancel them?
- I haven't so, let's walk through it.
So these were the days that...
- I need more power.
- You're gonna sit in there
and you can plug it in to your laptop.
I plugged in your laptop.
- By the way you and your sister,
from here are the same exact human being.
- I know.
- It was nuts. Like, this part,
it's so cool.
- She was like "I didn't even have
to say anything he was like,
"Yeah I got it."
- You know what's so funny
about your statement just now,
is like I'm never
going to win that game.
I mean like...
- [Voiceover] People don't
think you're that nice?
- That's right.
- [Woman] Well yeah but that's what it is.
- [Gary] Like if I came with that.
- But that's what it is.
- [Gary] Right.
- Yeah.
- Why because people are
just built to be cynical
or careful too good to be true?
- Yes but I think you're
also kind of a hard ass
and people probably think
that you're not going to be
as nice as you are.
- You mean depending on where
they capture the context of me
it may seem like I run a cult.
- They never are with you like
one-on-one in a conversation
and know how you really like listen.
They see you like up on stage, like...
- Yelling like "Fuck you" this.
- For everybody, there's Gary Vaynerchuk
and there's Gary Vay-ner-chuk.
(laughter)
- [Woman] That's an
excellent way to put it.
- Shut up, Nate.
(laughter)
- And then there's with
Nate and then it's just...
- You don't need me to print
out this guy's resume do you?
- There's so many moving parts right?
You know what you can do for me?
- Make a list.
- Of things that aren't going to happen.
Do me a favor and this
is actual real work,
so like get into a good zone,
put on some Bieber, whatever you do.
In the next 20, before Friday,
before Saturday morning or
maybe we do a call Saturday
for a quick minute.
I need to know what's not going to happen
and then look at what like
I'm willing to like cancel
to fit some of that to happen.
(upbeat instrumental music)